si el toque de queda que se ha impuesto
en esta tercera noche de guerra con
rusia consiste en que toda la población
y también los medios de comunicación no
pueden salir a la calle hasta las 8 de
la mañana de este lunes este toque de
queda
implica que las personas
que no cumplan con esta disposición
pueden ser considerados enemigos y por
tanto también exponerse a ser tiroteados
en el gobierno de que sea justificado
por esta disposición diciendo que esta
es la manera en que piensan a frenar la
entrada de saboteadores espías rusos que
estarían circulando por la ciudad y hace
tan sólo unos minutos hemos podido
nuevamente escuchar las sirenas y nuevos
también estallidos nuestra corresponsal
también nos contó que podría pasar esta
noche en kiev
pues la verdad es que nos esperamos una
noche muy larga y de nuevo de poco
dormir
después de que el ministerio de defensa
ruso dijera que planean a intensificar
la presión bélica sobre la ciudad de
quiebra después de estos primeros días
de combates en toda la ciudad lo que se
espera en esta noche es un aumento de
los bombardeos de los enfrentamientos
callejeros y por supuesto como también
decíamos antes un aumento de las bajas
no sólo militares sino también de
civiles pero habrá que realmente que
esperar para conocer exactamente lo que
ocurrirá esta noche